okay well here we are um this is our
first python lab which accompanies the
new edition of our book introduction to
statistical learning with applications
in Python and I'm sitting with Jonathan
Taylor who um is a python expert and we
got him to join us for this edition of
the book and so he's the fifth author
and he wrote all the labs and Jonathan's
going to take over the session and show
us how to get Pyon go and and and take
us through the first lab for chapter 2
thanks Trevor very happy to uh uh be
part of the the team for this book it's
been a lot of fun trying to uh write
these labs to and add a few things to to
statistics in Python uh that will go
along with this book um so I thought I'd
start off by just um in showing you how
to install what's needed uh for the
course there's a a package um a python
package that we'll have to install and
also just so we start almost from
scratch I'll just point out that here
I've uh I've downloaded the labs here
from the uh the book
website the python one and there's a zip
file for the notebook files over here
I've unpacked it into this directory
here and this is where these are the
labs we're going to be running um
includes a few data files um and that's
what we start we're going to be using um
this version of python shipped by
Anaconda I I've assumed you've
downloaded anaconda and installed it
that's a standard you know Mac install
um if you're using Windows it will be
installed in a similar fashion um but uh
this is this is how we're going to start
the session um and I I'll just show you
how to how to get set up uh as a um as a
first
task okay so here I've got an anonda
open and Anaconda has a a way to manage
sort of what code you're running by
these environments and I've made a
special environment for us uh and I
recommend you do the same um so I've
made an environment here called I islp
and uh you can make a new environment by
this create button um and I'll just do
that relatively quickly just to show you
if you had to do this yourself so I'll
call it islp 2
I'll create it and these environments
are sort of ways to isolate the code
you're running because in any sort of in
any modern you know Computing system
there's different versions of packages
and you want to kind of control them so
these environments are a way to control
them okay so there one more thing we
have to do besides making this
environment is we have to install the
code needed for the class so I'm just
going to do that by opening this
terminal and I'm going
to type one command I'll
just do it here we're going to install
the package with this line pip install
islp um I've already done that on my
session
but this will install what's needed um
for uh for the
course with the exception we'll see a
bit later of there's for the Deep
learning we'll have a few more installs
but we'll get to that uh uh in a few
Labs okay while that's running I'll go
back to my environment
that I've already
started um islp and we'll see how to
start a session so in this home there's
this um panel and we're going to run our
code in Jupiter lab so right now the
Jupiter lab um is I can launch it with
this button I will just say one more
quick thing if you're making this
environment yourself note you'll want
this tab up here to be the environment
you're running in the new environment
here if we look we'll see one thing that
the Jupiter
lab uh has not been installed we'd have
to install it before launching it so
let's just click that
one and then you'll see later it will
transition to be
launchable W you make this Look So Easy
Jonathan thanks uh it's really not hard
if I was able to do it it couldn't be
too hard thanks yeah so now it's
launchable and so this would launch a
new session um in this new environment
there if you're familiar if you for
using the terminal you and you have some
experience with python you can just run
pip in the terminal yourself um but this
way is simple way to do with a graphical
interface okay so that's how we uh get
set up and let's just go back to
our environment they're essentially
identical environments but I call this
one islp and we'll launch Jupiter lab
that should open something in your
browser something that looks something
like this and it's opened up here into
this the first lab that we'll look at um
the introduction to python
lab